je vous laisse en début de mois voilà
mais je raconte à chaque fois peut-être
vous la connaissez là je suis sûr que
michel et laulala connaissent c'est une
femme alors qu'elle rentrait chez elle
et elle trouve son mec avec une autre 9
et là il avec la meuf dans liszt à la
meuf l hyper v lire elle va chercher un
couteau dans la cuisine elle arrive
bah elle rentre dans la chambre elle
pond est lui couple atom elle prend la
tête l âge et par sexe il faut savoir je
sais pas si vous l'avez déjà fait une
top 10 donc la tob monnaie et la terre
se retrouvent sur un pare-brise et ya un
père de famille qui avec sa fille
derrière étoiles et la glace est là et
là le mec il est comme ça il est sur le
tard il est sur l'autoroute comme ça il
est [ __ ] dans la voiture avec sa fille
de lui faire un maire d'une top sur le
pare brise
c'est relou et tout il a fallu que ça
arrive à moi tout ça c'est vraiment
relou tout ça a beau il fait semblant de
rien mais les essuie glaces
l'acteur une top ça colle sur un
pare-brise faut le savoir donc là ça
n'est pas la somme de kiffa là un moment
il ya la petite qui fait papa papa c'est
quoi qui assure la voiture familiale à
affamer la wii sais rien j'ai chéri
syrien c'est un moustique mais la grosse
bête le moose
[Rires]
oui hakim
je crois que je n'ai une jeune retrouve
une parce que tout à l'heure c'était pas
mal elle est éclatée non c'est
l'histoire d'une d'une femme enceinte
ouais mais en fait donc on est enceinte
et va accoucher à l'hôpital et pousser
pousser pousser ça fait quand elle
pousse elle pousse vraiment fort très
fort et en fait le bébé il atterrit
contre le mur ou du coup bah ça arrive
pas de bébé terminée elle retombe
enceinte une deuxième fois
elle poussait le pousser le pousse les
pousses de mes pays et contre le mur n'a
encore encore deux fois
ah oui c'est intense et bizarre la
troisième fois on va appeler un gardien
de but tu vas te qu'il faut venir
fabien barthez d'accord à l'époque il va
pleuvoir casiraghi lui explique la
situation dit attention elle quand elle
avait c'est compliqué parce que le
pousser à chaque fois sa part donc on
sait pas que le côté ça appartient soyez
là quoi tu veux dire est inquiète c'est
bon elles poussent et poussent et
poussent le bébé s'en fout barthez il
attrape il attrapé la vf est sortie
illégalement
[Applaudissements]
il attend son premier enfant il fait les
cent pas dans la salle d'attenté
puisqu'il ne pas assister ce qui la rend
le conseiller pas trop regarder tout ça
et puis un peu long et où une infirmière
à rite alors ça y est c'est fait et oui
c'est fait il voit ton à sa mère n'est
pas très enthousiaste
qu'est-ce qui se passe il ya un problème
non non ça va commencer ça va bon on dit
ça sur un ton il ya un problème il est
handicapé il ya non non ça va il est pas
handicapé mais il est spécial comment ça
spécial ça veut dire quoi spéciale
écoutez je vous montrais est spécial et
là elle ouvre la porte de la chambre ils
ignorent sa femme il fonce vers le
berceau et là il voit un enfant black
avec les yeux bleus blonds et les yeux
[ __ ] et dit mais comment c'est
possible et comment c'est possible et sa
femme un peu gêné fait si chéri
rappelle-toi la partouze chez les martin
avec le black le chinois le ton copain
suédois ait été aux [ __ ] pourvu
qu'ils ne voient pas
[Applaudissements]